we have been called Indians more than a
hallucination
[Music]
tribal music club music mixed together
and made by these guys
I'm DJ Indian I'm tool men I'm bear
witness and we are attract all good
[Music]
we remix traditional powwow music with
contemporary club music First Nations
powwow music originated in the North
American Plains traditionally consists
of a large drum with singers and dancers
around it essentially follow music
traditional dance music that's why we
ended up doing what we do we're using
our music now in much the same way that
pal with you to create a gathering place
into A Tribe Called red powwow music
isn't just an adopted style it's a
significant part of their heritage
I'm Anishinabe from Nipissing First
Nations I grew up around pow wows and
going to powwow is there big cultural
gatherings the significance of us using
powwow and our music is just a way to
create something that represents
indigenous people and that indigenous
people can relate to their shows are a
cultural fusion experience combining
more than just sound but visuals - we
ended up hooking up with some people who
were doing the same thing we were doing
with dance there are native dance crew
there breakers that they mix it with
power so it's that same kind of fusion
and it's that combination of
contemporary and tradition that's
introducing indigenous culture to a
wider audience
I think when we started if you ask your
average non-indigenous person in Canada
if they had know what table music was
they would shrug and say no now I think
that's begun to change
[Music]